[Music]  foreign  [Music]  [Music]  foreign  this is europe this is you know this is  this is a dictator who's on  in our neighborhood so to speak in our  european neighborhood with ambitions to  recreate rebuild and imperialist russia  this isn't going to end in ukraine this  didn't end in chechnya it didn't end in  georgia it didn't end in crimea it's not  going to end with ukraine no they're not  doing enough on sanctions it's pathetic  absolutely pathetic  because  they're not taking immediate effect  they need to seize these assets  immediately and i'd like to see the  proceeds of these assets actually going  into a fund  which will then be used to rebuild  ukraine  [Music]